antonio brown managed to take a
situation where he was under contract
for three more years and parlay that
into a new three-year contract that's
going to pay him over 50 million dollars
assuming he's there for all three years
either way he's guaranteed 30 million
plus when he was previously guaranteed
nothing so how did he pull this off well
from the raiders perspective before we
say they paid too much consider how
these deals typically work you take into
account what you're giving up to the
other team to trade for a player and
what you are paying the player and in
this case because the raiders were able
to get antonio brown for only a third
round pick and a fifth-round pick it was
easier to justify paying him more money
now the more they have to give the
steelers to get brown the less they
would be willing to give him under the
terms of a contract so by virtue of the
fact the steelers were so desperate to
move brown that they were willing to
take only a three and a five that
allowed brown to unlock a new contract
that has that guaranteed money that his
previous deal did not have and when you
look at his contract when you compare it
to others like odell beckham jr sami
watkins
antonio brown for now has a better deal
than any of them and he managed to do it
without becoming a free agent without
getting to the open market and despite
having three years left on the contract
that he signed with pittsburgh just two
years ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports